yunus et squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur happy l écouter aujourd'hui
la fermeture de petites filles comme à
l'époque avec les défis de squeeze c'est
un joueur agents dans qu'elle va mourir
un paquet de fois et à chaque mois on
prendra une petite cuillère de tabasco
voilà après s'être pris des coups d'être
citée la semaine dernière et cette
semaine c'est le tabasco à les talons
bien c'est carrément que j'ai tout quoi
et je gagne quoi si je vais là bas par
exemple je ne prends pas à la ps3 du
tabasco dès le début pour y aller comme
ça hop hop hop presse b tous les bits
est objet quizz ou qui ponot je n'ai
rien compris mais je suis oda au pc le
banc le plus pourri comment sont eux
tous les enfants oh [ __ ] mais qui là
mais j'ai pu couvrir 30 m à ce que j'ai
depuis dix ans qu'il a fait remonter
comme pas possible que mes chiens en
fait les mains là je crois que ça va me
permettre d'attaquer derrière des choses
mais là y'a jamais comment avez vous
géré par les eaux est ce moi j'allais
voilà c'est bon j'ai eu la main je peux
m'en aller pardon non mais on comprend
pas tabasco sur sa non mais hors de
question et j'ai la bouche gens fous ça
suffit mais pourquoi je me fais attaquer
par du plié mais qu'un mais c'est quoi
ce jeu il ya des nez qui volent des
pieds de là la voilà je vais crever
salua mais oui mais mais j'ai de quoi
que pour la lapine trois thoniers quoi
celle-ci c'est que d'enjeux que ça
arrive je sens que ça le montage de
cette vidéo va se faire aux toilettes
c'est sûr et certain fait que part
j'aimerais bien mais je crois que ça sur
les goûts des français que c'est comme
public haute pour les pizzas coutu a
depuis longtemps avec des trottinettes
pitié c'est mon choix en vie à leur gré
immédiat c'est incroyable pour rien
[ __ ] mais c'est juste y a que des
trucs improbables en fait les mains
rouges comme la main là bas là il faut
que je ramasse ça me permet ensuite de
taper ou de faire chez pas quoi on passe
ce job
oui mais quelle [ __ ] donc à temps aux
médecins guinguette à pied la hoya
l'éolien ce vieux pieds qui me faire
vieux guet-apens par toi non non non
c'est bon c'est bon fantastic elle fait
quoi et caméras il veut nous faire
observer au paysage de la chine comment
ça se passait au nom mais qu on est bon
on est bon les bons des boues ouais on
est bien là oh [ __ ] pied non
franchement je pensais pas que
s'applique autant est ce que j ai pas
souvenir que s'appliquer autant jeu
c'est vrai que c'est le genre de truc
qui a été créé pour qu'on en prenne avec
le jus de tomate et ensuite pour qu'on
apprenne quand on fait une vidéo sur la
chaîne de squeeze batte un jour où j à
vue d'oeil si génial vous avez vu ça
sans trucage 1
au pelage décrivent la grand pic à 6
langues je peux jouer un look in des
droits bientôt j'aurai le zombie
figurera au fond on n'a pas atteint mais
pour à la main mais je suis pas morte
soit envahi offert là je suis là dedans
il se passe rien il ya des bulles à je
peux plus je peux plus c'est un truc de
fou
à l'aller les rougeurs quoi je me sens
pas bien j'ai des vertiges quoi c'est
faux j'avais cru moi pas le choix je
crois quoi fois elle est là explique
avoir eu quoi et bien un truc à faire à
la fin vers la tête là attendez je me
sens bien oui il ya bien un truc aussi
le meilleur jeu du monde
bonjour je suppute à bouger vos survivre
que en train de mourir à ok on peut
passer de drogba mais c'est quoi ça ça
fait deux morts allait à la voie au
talent et je pense qu'à un moment j'en
pouvais plus là au moins je vais craquer
comme le kraken permis car on sait d'où
[ __ ] des cas plus tard et ce coup-ci
house a vu ses yeux il croît de joie
paul la barre et je le fais car 90
secondes et a40 [ __ ] elle va arriver
je le sais voilà c'était paix que voit
le peu que michael jackson a assez drôle
à gillois parce que je suis sous tabasco
vous voyez c'est un petit peu comme
l'alcool et toutes ces conneries en
beaucoup moins nocif
oh [ __ ] et si on touche à rien mon
gars en question à faire
bon j'en prendrais alors associé jean
michel bouche la barre en bas âge à 10,4
surtout propre sud aig et une aussi à la
manette et tout ce qui est présent ici
en plus jour pire jouer du monde avec le
pire défis du monde
cette technique de fer petite brise dans
ma langue
alors qu'en fait c'est totalement
ridicule c'est dû lâcher à chaque mort
non mais là les gars il est d'une
violence rare show est le team met des
coups comme ça mais ça suffit [ __ ]
aujourd'hui la mouche va s'en sortir je
voulais rejoindre le gasc vous entendre
on sait jamais où les entorses que
beaucoup de peur ça qu'on entend les pas
des ennemis je ne peux plus parler je
suis tétanisée sur la douleur ça ma
relaxe et voilà en fait c'est un
entraînement pour les poumons
il amène à sardines qu'un avant le
saumon je peux plus j'arrive plus donc
je ne peux plus parler je ne peux plus
regarder droit chemin que j'ai pas vu et
met un coup d' aller mal faire ça
soulage
je vous jure ça soulage moi je suis beau
faire c'est ce qu'il faut faire
alem et joueurs pour tirer mugler [ __ ]
je veux chanter je pense ça va super
bien aller avec ce qui se passe
actuellement aller un petit truc de
tabasco pour pour la route
l'acea tristesse que ya dans ma bouche
et dans mes poumons absolue dans ce
match était fait
et without you just listen to il attend
ils n'étaient pas au mexique mais les
kwasa groupe f au short stack des pubs
découvre alors d'assaut tôt je m'en fous
volkswagen en fout moi c'est abbas comme
en voiture ce n'est pas parce qu aussi
elle met le faux sur l'autoroute vous ai
compris ça pique donc le commande ce qui
n'est le vieux cela ce fort hier en fait
parler doucement ça fait de l'air sur un
nom il s'appelle encore plus mama mama
mama mama y langue me pique que toy
story fine cette langue piquera plus un
peu de lait d'amour des abonnés le
refrain le refrain maintes au mama mama
mama mama malan me pique ça suffit
pressé non je mords attendent vais quand
même faire injure à jour à chaque mois
on prenait damas coup on se retrouve ce
karaoké par ticket c'est que ce bordel
oui donc ce sprint juin à monsieur
tablette dans lequel on voit pas mal
mourir le truc c'est d'anticiper un saut
comme ça est pris pour arriver au bon
endroit [ __ ] comment c'est un calcul
damasco au jeu je commence à péter des
caps quoi à oliva je peux pas enchaîner
à ce stade vous savez vous savez je peux
pas les capacités gustatif de dôme le
mec c'est un truc de ouf
oh oh oh oh qu'est la joie bien tu avais
juste debout que de prendre tout ce à
quoi ils jouent aux brestois n'assume
plus c'est la fin pour et par le wall
voulez je peux vous dire allez vas-y au
nom trop loin [ __ ] c'est un beau
bonjour parcouru se trouve dans les
bonnes notes
oh mon dieu mais sans déconner si la
vidéo la plus dégueulasse da
j'ai fait un saut ça va expulser moi je
vais faire un saut au sol en euros en
caisse et or c'est vrai je n'ai plus de
langues
voilà ce la gratuité de cette vidéo à aa
on va pas top up et à d'autres corps de
plongeon on a battu c'est tout ce qu'on
a battu ici présents au plat au plat
hop là hop là oh là là on a battu rouen
oh la la aulas non non ah je suis ou la
vidéo va être très content mais là
j'arrive à saturation de tous les côtés
du corps je veux dire la bouche comme
les fesses je peux plus ça dont je
m'habille comme ça dessus au plat allez
vous résidez oh la la
oh là là mais non mais non mais non mais
je fais plus cheveux plus je peux plus
se rebelle opère un score enfin à ont
été menés au score et amputations non je
vais y tourna key jeu plus qu'attendu en
août à tout ça c'est les infos qui nous
ont pas donné les [ __ ]
oh oui attac ou alors la ola battus mais
leur histoire alors là je suis lancé je
lancé jean-michel ne s'arrête plus aulas
9 et le 10 pts 10
on s'en fout on n'a pas le dit c'est ta
j'ai sous-estimé ce défi c'est un truc
de dingue bel emballage de la fin de
cette vidéo je mets ça vous a plu moi
pas trop vraiment j'ai trop poussé soit
bouteille c'est parce qu on s'en doute
trop lisse dans une prochaine vidéo
beaucoup moins qu'au rassurez-vous merci
à vous regarder
théo tout le monde te pisse